antes de hablar más acerca de la
desigualdad será mejor que hablemos
acerca de la diferencia entre ingreso y
riqueza pues me parece que muchas veces
se confunden sobre todo en
conversaciones acerca de desigualdad
como se pueden imaginar ambos términos
van de la mano una persona que tiene
mucha riqueza también va a tener mucho
ingreso o alguien que tiene un ingreso
grande es probable que tenga más riqueza
sin embargo estos términos no son
sinónimos la riqueza puede verse como el
valor de capital o bienes que les
pertenecen vamos a escribirlo valor de
capital
o bienes
que son tuyos
mientras que el ingreso es la cantidad
de dinero que se gana o se recibe o se
percibe durante cierto periodo de tiempo
va a ser la cantidad ganada o percibida
en cierto periodo
y ambos tienen a moverse juntos pero
esto no siempre es el caso vamos a ver
un ejemplo de esto digamos que hay una
persona jubilada que puede tener
bastante riqueza ya que tuvo toda una
vida de ingresos que ahorro podemos
imaginar que esta persona es tu abuelo y
tiene una riqueza o un valor total de
esos bienes
de un millón de dólares
pero esta persona ya no está trabajando
más pues está jubilado su ingreso total
es el interés que recibe de este millón
de dólares imaginemos que esta persona
invirtió este millón de dólares en
instrumentos de poco riesgo bonos o
cosas similares
así que recibe un ingreso de este millón
tiene digamos 3% después de impuestos
por lo que su ingreso es de 300 mil
dólares anuales
por otro lado imaginemos que aquí estás
tú y acabas de salir de la universidad
por lo que es probable que tú tengas más
deuda que riqueza porque digamos que
tienes un auto que vale 20 mil dólares
pero tienes una deuda por préstamo
universitario de 40 mil dólares por lo
que tienes una riqueza de menos 20 mil
dólares pero todo lo que invertiste en
esa educación le estás dando muy buen
uso ya que te permite conseguir un muy
buen trabajo por lo que ahora tienes un
ingreso de 80 mil dólares anuales
en esta situación una persona más joven
puede tener más deudas que riquezas o
riquezas negativas pero tiene un buen
ingreso en cambio una persona jubilada
puede tener mucha riqueza pero un
ingreso menor esto que he planteado aquí
muestra situaciones extremas desde una
persona joven que tiene un muy buen
ingreso pero tiene deudas hasta una
persona mayor que vive de los intereses
de su riqueza acumulada de los ahorros
de toda una vida como pueden ver estos
conceptos están correlacionados por
ejemplo cuando el ingreso es grande
imaginamos que este abuelo ahorro 10
millones de dólares durante su vida en
lugar de sólo un millón y lo está
invirtiendo de la misma manera que en el
ejemplo anterior por lo que el 3% de 10
millones es trescientos mil dólares
anuales trescientos mil dólares anuales
los cuales van a ser sus ingresos por
año
obviamente conforme crece la riqueza
crecerá el ingreso que proviene de dicha
riqueza y
posible que dicho ingreso sea mayor del
que podríamos tener de un sueldo pero el
propósito de este vídeo es resaltar las
diferencias entre estos dos términos
algunas veces cuando las personas hablan
sobre desigualdad o disparidad o
riquezas acumuladas en un segmento de la
población otras veces las personas
hablan del ingreso nacional acumulado
que cada vez llega más a las manos del
1% o del 10% de los más ricos de la
población en estas charlas se mencionan
estos dos términos pero es importante
conocer la diferencia entre ellos